và bỏ thì chắc chắn sẽ có từng bài đâu.
Giờ đọc đặt cơ,
có thật là chúng ta nhận nhìn hơn
thấy chương mạnh mẽ hơn.
Bốn mấy làm đến sống như quốc thì mà người có thể đốt
tầm muốn tầm người và tầm chăm khá lời.
Sò với những mù kẹt thì nó sẽ nhiều hơn.
Bốn mù này là doi hỏi rất là lực khác.
Cái như đồng tác có thật,
có thật hợp với mùi nghe cắt thơm lại
là nếu mà mình tập có thức không,
bỗ trợ cho mình tử bệnh
khi eu có vẻ khi nó sẽ không có vẻ là lực khác chăm nhập mục tòm,
có gắng mình tập là nó sẽ không.
Thật như là đồng tác mua hay hó,
dân nó ngọt.
Lần đồng hòa,
lần mình bất cứ hòa,
trước đây thì mình không không có mỗi nó,
cũng hòa hóa hóa hóa phải sảy đó,
phải chẳng nó thù lầy.
Thì phải gần, có khá yên hòa.
Một khán thì mình lại có thể bắt kịt
được tính độc bếc cơ đại,
giống như mà có những kết trường hòa,
bất khảy chán,
sĩ rẻ,
mình có thể nhớ được tính độc bếng mạng mạng mạng gửi ấy.
Thì bắt buộc đồng tử bếng,
giảy vừa,
thì bắt buộc đồng bếng,
phải án ủng đầy đồng bếng nè.
Có bình nở như tình mà cũng sẽ không như cái quyền khó đình,
sau đó có cùm kỳ nó mò hóa,
mong người đến thầm hơn nữa,
bất ngờ,
tài gọi là gắp đồng ý,
một tồn như dạy là hòa,
có tựng thầm,
nằm người nó bước mọi lớp bố môi nổi gọi là chân hẹn.